right side of the floor it's going to be
Drew holiday just going right at Newark
ik and he just walks into that screens
he got stripped already got five
rebounds in the game and a law for Davis
I want Anthony Davis a candidate for MVP
Defensive Player of the Year his path to
the rim I'm feeding on the skill on
display in the NC double-a tournament
last year as a member of Gonzaga he left
as Clark hits a three was drafted 10th
overall by Sacramento and traded at
Portland Davis behind the back gets to
the rim floats it off the window at home
he's got 13 Meritage pulls the trigger
good on a three okay I like that there
was no hesitation this game to an
entirely different level and again it's
not get out on the perimeter which
leaves a meto
here comes New Orleans 48 wins during
the regular season
Meritage splashes home of three McCallum
for three no good Rondo quick pass to
more down court for an easy two 14
assists now Ferrando will be many
daggers
Rober nose Davis what a putback in a
foul water an incredible play and he'll
go to the line
well the frustration of Ed Davis that
he's called for the foul but I'm not
sure what he's complaining about him yet
checksum and he clearly catches on on
the arm I mean he checks him and he
clearly catches him on the arm
I mean you have 16 assists as well
[Applause]
look for Davis what the one-handed
flocks Rondo and complete command of the
south that's understanding I've got one
of the best players of the league
rolling right now labas perfectly placed
Anthony makes easy work of it rolling
right now lob is perfectly placed and
that he makes easy work of it he had 16
assists as well love for Davis with the
one-handed flush
they're accustomed to that level of
productivity from him Davis on the cut
what a pass by Mirotic and Davis is over
the 30 point